my favorite clip that has gone around
since ice ice spice's new song when so I
guess it's only been in the last 24
hours my favorite clip in any case that
has been going around the internet is
care of a woman named Suki Hana and
another woman named Bobby altof who is a
young podcaster I take it and they were
uh really almost coming to blows over
the host's suggestion that the musician
is a
musician what do you know that you're a
musician but that's why I'm interviewing
you today so I can get to know you so
I'm a musician mhm what the that mean
make magic or something what is musician
I think that's I think you're confusing
that yeah I'm not no musician I make
music I make music and that's not all I
do I make music I act I'm a TV star too
a young M just really quick I think
you're confusing I'm not confusing
nothing because you you don't know you
thought that all I was was a magician or
whatever the you say see that's what I
think you think I said I said musician
not magician I don't think baby I don't
think what is that that's ghetto I don't
think I know so you you think I didn't
say magician Suki I said
musician and I think you are a musician
no baby I do music so you just really
just really quick for the record could
you say you don't think you're a
musician I'm not none of that but then
after that you just said I do music yeah
I do music so in other words you're a
musician no I'm not
okay who's on first who's on second no
who's On First I don't know Third Base
that's what this is this is obviously a
bit some people were sharing this as
though this were a sincere
miscommunication it's obviously a bit
and it's a very funny
bit it's a it's a version in a way of
like an old Abbott and Costello routine
but it's also and and this is more to
the cultural Point here the specific
kind of bit this is is a minstral act
and we live at a time where we're
erasing all sorts of characters and all
sorts of uh shows and forms of Art and
jokes because they're supposedly racist
and they're supposedly racist because
they come from minstral SE we got rid of
ant Jima from the pancake syrup bottle
because it was supposedly uh so racist
deriving from the minstral tradition and
and it does the anima character does
come from the minstral tradition uh the
irony it is that the anima character was
created by a black writer named Billy
cand who is one of the most famous
minstral performers in history but we're
not allowed to do that now anytime a
woman puts a little too much uh
concealer on for Halloween we're all
trying to figure out if if she put on
black face and to see if we can cancel
her because you got to get rid of
minstral th but this is a minstral act
and everyone's laughing at it right now
because they refuse to acknowledge that
just like the Tracy Morgan character in
30 Rock was a it was a funny bit but it
was a minstral bit the whole the joke of
it was he's a caricature of black
culture and he seems kind of dumb and
you know he he seems uh silly and
frivolous and it's kind of funny it's
funny you know to make fun of any kind
of a culture but we're told
intellectually today you're not in any
way allowed to make fun of black people
except we all we do it it's not us I
didn't it a bunch of Libs made dirty
Rock I am quite certain that Suki and
this host Bobby alof are not right-wing
conservatives they're probably not Trump
supporters right even the the sitcoms of
the 1970s great shows The Jeffersons
Good Times all those Norman Lear shows
they were they were kind of minstral
shows so all of this to say it's not
that I'm defending minstral C or
whatever I'm not defending sukiana or
any of these people uh my point is more
a historical point we look back and we
throw stones at all of our forebears and
all how racist our grandparents were and
how evil and rotten and terrible
everyone was whoever came before
us we are doing the exact same
things and in in many cases what we are
doing today is much worse take the
theatrical tradition and comedy bits
aside for a second we we like to look
back on history and say can you believe
that
for two or 3 hundred years in America we
tolerated a particular egregious form of
slavery yeah man that's terrible you
know we kill 800,000 babies a year now
you know that right no no no that's good
Michael that's autonomy that's Freedom
that yeah I'm just saying in the future
maybe people will look kind of
negatively on that seems a little crazy
to me everyone's going to be laughing at
this bit everyone but when we look back
in history people do the same kind of
things these same themes that recur
throughout history it's bad when they do
it it's fine when we do it it's very bad
when they do it speaking of putting on
an act
nearly half
[Music]
of uh speaking
of there's a Missouri Secretary of State
candidate who is
uh she's got maybe the greatest campaign
ad of the year uh her campaign ad
consists in lighting LGBT books that are
put in front of little kids on
fire this is what I will do to the groom
books when I become Secretary of
State these books Public Library when
I'm in office they will
[Music]
burn now hold on hold on a second I have
a question about this ad and my question
is
what is the maximum donation Allowed by
law that one can make to a Missouri
Secretary of State
candidate that that's my only question
actually what an ad what an ad Valentina
Gomez a woman on a
mission when I'm in office these books
will burn now I know book bans and book
burning they get a a bad rap these days
but
uh virtually every serious thinker for
all of history has has supported some
degree of book Banning or censorship and
many of them supported book burning
going back to I don't know like Plato
the
apostles um the the great Geniuses of
the Middle Ages the
Scholastics even people who are not not
exactly on my side of viewing things you
know I think like Martin Luther you know
not my main man but that guy burned
books that you know you get this recur
URS throughout history okay and we have
plenty of book bands today what's funny
is that the libs pretend they always
have these lists of the most banned
books and it's always like to Kill a
Mockingbird or something one of the
bestselling novels ever that every
school child reads by the time he's 12
that's not a Banned
Book there there are legitimately banned
books go like a some like Holocaust
denying historian that's a banned go try
to buy one of those books you're not
going to find that anywhere and I'm not
I'm not arguing that certain books
shouldn't be banned it's the libs who
are saying that certain books shouldn't
be banned but they're the ones who ban
all the books forget about books that
that most people would object to even
just get down to the the one book you're
not allowed to teach in schools the
Bible That's the book The Libs support
that book ban they would probably burn
it if they had the
chance but they're going to get on this
woman they'll say she's a threat she's
an authoritarian she wants to censor
that
woman compared to the liberal
establishment that woman is as
open-minded as they come what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey hey come
on Jack come on man Corn Pop ring that
Bell we'll see you next time